but first a developing story in the east
side of town metro police say a man
found dead inside a home and his son may
be involved so this has all been
unfolding over the last few hours in a
neighborhood not too far from tropicana
and boulder highway that's where we find
victoria saha who just heard an update
from police tonight victoria
yeah denise and brian it's still a very
active scene here on the 500 block of
sageland street i'm going to have my
photog zoom over there the police are
still surrounding one of those houses
where this all unfolded the body of that
victim we're told is still inside as the
coroner and homicide detectives continue
their investigation
neighbors in metro police confirm a man
lived in one of those houses he was in
mental distress and called his family
yesterday his father flew in from
northern california yesterday afternoon
to check on him but then his wife didn't
hear from him after that that concerned
the wife and their other son who came
down to see what was going on and called
police to do a welfare check because
neighbors say they heard gunshots but
neighbors say police left shortly after
and then the wife went to the house to
find her husband dead with a gunshot
wound that is when police returned to
the scene and it turned into a barricade
situation because their prime suspect is
that son who lived there after no
contact for several hours police went
inside but did not find the suspect
several neighbors nearby were evacuated
but were not allowed back into their
house until recently but they have to be
have to have shelter in place i spoke to
a couple of neighbors they said that
they just saw that sun yesterday morning
but nothing seemed unusual again stay
with us for any updates on this story
that suspect is still on the run tonight
reporting from the east valley tonight
victoria saha live local now